on constate qu'il y a toujours quelques
réticences et réserves y compris parmi
les personnels soignants
alors que leurs charges quotidien c'est
quand même bien de prendre en charge les
malades les fragiles et les plus
vulnérables
donc comment pouvons nous communiquer
pour mieux expliquer la nécessité de la
vaccination dans ces milieux
professionnels et comment développer là
les verts pour les personnels soumis à
l'obligation vaccinale et je pense en
particulier aux aides soignants qui
dansaient personnel ou un taux de
vaccination plus faibles par ailleurs
bon force est de constater que le pass
sanitaire généralisée à une large
palette d'activités et au minimum une
incitation à la vaccination mais ça peut
être considéré aussi comme une forme
d'obligation qui moi personnellement ne
me choque pas
que pensez vous de cette stratégie pour
améliorer la couverture vaccinale en
population générale
et que pensez-vous d'aller vers une
obligation généralisée et puis sur la
suggestion du ministre de la santé
est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler les
niveaux de protection pour une personne
qui aurait fait un qu'ovide pour une
personne vaccinée après la première dose
et le taux de protection après achema
vaccinale complet je vous remercie
merci on nous allons peut-être prendre
d'autres questions valérie boyer merci
madame la présidente
j'aurais plusieurs questions si vous le
permettez la première parce que je n'ai
pas compris la réponse du ministre alors
monsieur delfraissy je me permets de
vous la poser quelles sont les mesures
concrètes que vous avez mises en place
pour aller chercher on va dire les plus
de 50 ans qui ne sont pas encore
vaccinés comment les suit on est parce
que tout à l'heure le ministre a dit le
barnum et des barnums en bas des
immeubles certains certains coups de fil
et sait comment sont associés les
pharmaciens les médecins traitants et
surtout quelle est la contribution des
services de l'assurance maladie pour les
suivre ensuite j'ai une autre question
comment le rappel de ceux qui ont eu une
première dose et qu'ils organisent et
est-ce qu'on va recevoir un message sms
et y compris je mets dans le rappellent
ceux qui ont eu enfin ceux qui
éventuellement pourraient être éligibles
à une troisième dose on verra mais déjà
ceux ceux pour qui la deuxième dose est
requise
comment va-t-on le savoir où vont-ils
tomber dans le dans les statistiques des
non vaccinés s'ils ne font pas leur
appel à temps et je voudrais juste me
permettre de faire une remarque
effectivement la lutte contre la grive
ou plus grave encore contre le sida
ce sont des épidémies des pandémies
enfin des des chocs qui se sont faits
par la pédagogie l'information
l'accompagnement est pas la répression
est effectivement
pour le grenadier russe on est dans une
sorte dans un autre paradigme un
changement aussi de société donc je
voulais savoir comment alors que nous
entrons dans un climat absolument
détestable où on montre les vacciner
contre les non vaccinés les pros passent
contre les anti passe et cetera comment
on va faire pour convaincre les français
encore récalcitrants de la nécessité
d'être vacciné surtout comment hal
comment quelles sont les mesures qui
sont mises en place pour les suivre
merci monsieur delfraissy vous est
peut-être mais ces voiliers mais ce
professeur est peut-être répondre à
cette première série sinon je devrai
d'abord répondre de façon générale ne
confondez pas moi je suis on reçoit les
frais si je suis un malheureux médecin
embarqué dans une dans une longue
aventure je ne pourrais pas répondre
pour les autorités sanitaires le conseil
scientifique vous le savez veille à
avoir une forme d'autonomie de penser il
livre un certain nombre de réflexions je
ne pourrais pas répondre pour le miz la
santé je peux vous éclairer et b bien
sûr je répondrai pas vocation mais pas
pour le miz la santé c'est nous sommes
d'avec des fonctions totalement
différente
premièrement sur l'obligation vaccinale
chez les soignants
oui c'est un sujet ça sue est difficile
on a pris position au niveau du conseil
scientifique 1 vous l'avez vu dans notre
avis du 6 juillet j'ai et j'ai changé
d'avis j'ai changé d'avis sur le sujet
initialement j'étais pour le convaincre
à les verts
bon et ça a marché quand on regarde quel
était le niveau de vaccination chez les
soignants au mois de janvier au mois de
février et celui auquel on est arrivé
maintenant il ya une importante
évolution
mais en france on parle uniquement des
trucs qui marchent porte mais ça a
marché
et puis on reste après sur une fraction
difficile on y reviendra et en
particulier vous savez que le niveau de
couverture vaccinale chez les médecins
et aytré pratiquement optimale à et que
par contre plus on est diminué on va
vers des métiers d'un type aides
soignants plus on a de la difficulté à
faire passer ce message
on a laissé six mois et moi j'ai changé
d'avis parce qu'il ya un moment donné
que je suis fondamentalement médecin et
il ya un moment donné quand on choisit
ce métier autour de la santé on le doit
aux autres on fait ce métier pour les
autres on le fait pas pour soi et donc
on leur a laissé le choix
et puis maintenant on sait qui a
scientifiquement qui est un certain
nombre de places qui sont arrivés qui a
des infections qui arrive à partir des
soignants que les soignants sont les
soignants mais son side citoyens et
qu'ils vivent normalement qu'ils ont les
mêmes qui ne s'infecte pas forcément
l'hôpital qui peuvent s'arrêter ailleurs
et donc de passer avec une obligation
vaccinale m'apparaît je dirais du
domaine du raisonnable et qui après il
va falloir être convaincant c'est un set
aux équipes c'est tôt qu'on le fasse pas
de façon administrative qu'on les cons
les convainc que ce médecin de le faire
c'est aux médecins de les aider à passer
ce cap parce que je peux vous dire mais
j'ai pas d'état d'âme surpasser à
l'obligation vaccinale chez les
soignants d'aller on l'a écrit s'il y
avait un état d'âme se seraient pas bien
le deuxième
le deuxième point c'était sur le pass
sanitaires
comme comme la question vous poser c'est
pas sanitaire en obligations généralisée
de la vaccination
alors on à moi je reste moi en retrait
vis-à-vis de l'obligation vaccinale et
de en population générale
je reste concentré parce que je pense
que l'on santé publique
ce n'est pas la mesure qui vais prix ce
qui est fondamental elle est importante
mais c'est son acceptabilité et c'est
l'impact même de la mesure qui va faire
qui va contribuer dans une certaine
mesure aussi à faire évoluer
je dirais la pensée du citoyen et je ne
crois pas que l'obligation vaccinale
dans le contexte actuel
dans ce contexte extrêmement difficile
pour nous tous était la meilleure
solution
donc vous avez vu ce qu'on écrit dans
notre avis du 6 juillet c'est c'était de
mettre en place au niveau juridique est
donc je savais que derrière c'était au
niveau bien sûr législatif et c'est pour
ça qu'on est que je suis là ce matin
c'était d'aller vers la constitution des
faits de ce pass sanitaires sur le fond
je ne le regrette vraiment pas du tout
et j'ai re interrogées demandent des
conseils scientifiques nous sommes nous
pensons que c'est pour l'instant pour
l'instant en tout cas une solution qui
permet d'aller vers une plus grande
acceptabilité vaccinable après sur les
modalités ne nous regarde pas ce sont
des modalités qui relève des
gouvernements et des autorités
sanitaires
et moi je dirais qu'il faut le faire
avec le plus de souplesse possible et
j'y reviendrai sur la question vous
allez poser tout à l'heure sur la place
des citoyens et de la vision citoyenne
dans le temps dans cette pandémie bien
sûr qu'il faut du dialogue
si on regarde qui n'est pas vacciné
actuellement vous le savez le ministre a
dû le dire où vous le savez en lisant
quand on reprend la carte sur les 10 %
de plus de 60 ans qui sont pas vaccinés
sur les sujets à risque de moins de 60
ans qui ne sont pas vaccinés et en
particulier
sur les sujets ayant un surpoids n'est
pas que si vous prenez cette carte avec
une analyse géographique et économique
un peu fine en micro qui retrouve des
études qui ont été réalisées par
nathalie bajos par ailleurs vous voyez
que il y à une concordance entre les la
population qui est en excitation
vaccinale et la population qui est
sociétalement économiquement le plus
défavorisé
vous l'avez rappelé j'insiste beaucoup
là-dessus j'ai beaucoup insisté auprès
du gouvernement pour que cette quatrième
vague ne soit pas seulement une vague
pour l'ensemble de la société
bon pour nous tous bien sûr qu'elle ne
soit pas seulement d'ordre sanitaire
avec l'impact sur sur le système de
soins que j'ai évoquée pour la fin août
mais qu'elle ne soit pas surtout une
vague sociétale à 7 quand on le sait
danser pandémie finalement elles ne font
que révéler les discordances qui peut y
avoir et les dissociation qui peut y
avoir au niveau d'accès à la santé et là
on est dans un an on pourrait avoir une
quatrième vague extrêmement sociétale et
c'est là où il faut qu'on fasse très
attention
donc c'est cette population un peu mal
cerné qu'il faut conduire expliqué entre
guillemets pour pour là pour l'aider à
prendre la décision et a passé de
l'hésitation vaccinale à se faire
vacciner
c'est un point essentiel il n'est pas
utile doit jouer évidemment dans les
constitutions du pass solitaire je pense
et les études ont montré que le la
vision très top down 2
il faut faire etc elle est nécessaire
mais pas suffisante et qu'il faut qu'on
aille vers une stratégie beaucoup plus
localisées s'appuyant sur le milieu
associatif
s'appuyant sur les mairies s'appuyant
sur sur un certain nombre de peu de
masse de structures qui sont habitués à
avoir à travailler avec ces populations
les plus complexes et c'est pas que 9,3
ça existe également dans les territoires
et on le sait tous
et ça existe dans le pays perry très
grande banlieue parisienne où ou dans un
certain nombre de très grandes
métropoles de province
et là il ya un effort considérable
encore à faire mais très difficile parce
que c'est la période d'été mais pour
accélérer et pour travailler avec les
grandes associations pas du tout dudule
sanitaires mais des associations qui ont
l'habitude de travailler que ces
populations et j'insiste vraiment
là-dessus
c'est probablement ce qui est pas mis
suffisamment mis en avant actuellement
donc je passe un petit peu de temps
là-dessus parce que cette vision de
l'épidémie d'une quatrième vague
sociétale est donc d'essayer de leur
éviter qu'ils soient le plus impacté
giresse nôtres c'est notre devoir à tous
de citoyens à 2 degrés divers d'essayer
de limiter cette vague sur cette
population alors sur les autres
questions sur la première dose et coûter
cher
bon je crois que je mangeais pas de
souci là-dessus c'est à dire que on est
dans un modèle qui est le modèle de
vaccination les gens vont pas recevoir
une convocation pour la deuxième dose
ils ont isis ils vont être dans le
modèle classique de vaccination ils se
font vacciner
il ya eu l'ouverture vous l'avez vue qui
est en train de se faire sur la capacité
à vaccination bon ils auront une
deuxième date
eh ben ils prendront cette deuxième date
ils vont pas ce jeune je ne peux que je
n'ai pas compris qu'ils auraient une
convocation spécifique durant l'été pour
cette deuxième pour cette deuxième
vaccination je réponds peut-être pas là
votre question mais je bois voilà comme
je vois les choses sûres
sur l'accompagnement je vous ai répondu
je ré insiste là-dessus
au risque de vous lasser un peu mais
tant pis c'est mon rôle moi je suis issu
vous le savez très bien du monde du vih
je je je suis issu de cette de cette
génération de médecins qui a vécu
l'échec aussi j'ai déjà vécu l'échec et
ensuite j'ai vécu et c'est pour ça que
je suis optimiste
on va gagner mais j'ai vécu pendant très
longtemps une forme d'échec donc j'ai
vécu le fait que pour à la fois sur les
aspects transmission sur les aspects de
compréhension d'une maladie sur les
aspects de prévention la construction
avec l'individu avec le milieu
associatif était quelque chose de
fondamental
je regrette je les écris que nous ne
l'ayons pas plus fait est que les
autorités sanitaires depuis le début de
la crise ne se soit pas plus appuyé sur
ce que j'avais évoqué comme étant un
comité citoyen qui aurait pu être une
voie de transmission entre guillemets ou
de discussion un espace de discussion ça
n'a pas été fait bon je constate aussi
avec plaisir que ça s'est fait dans les
grandes métropoles 1 sur grenoble lyon
bordeaux marseille paris sur rennes un
certain nombre de sécabilité s'est mis
en place et je constate que là on est à
une troisième étape et c'est une belle
opportunité pour le faire pour aller
vers ces populations qui représente les
populations qui ne sont pas les
populations vaccinées s'appuyer sur le
tissu associatif sur le tissu local sur
les mairies sur sur les masses
en face sur une série d'acteurs locaux
qui sont fondamentaux la crédibilité de
la parole politique
la crédibilité de la parole médicale et
scientifique
vous avez bien compris qu'elle est
beaucoup remise en cause et je le
comprends parfaitement donc appuyons
nous sur les acteurs locaux pour toucher
ces jeunes populations qui sont
défavorisés ceux variante delta à un
niveau de transmission a nettement plus
élevée joue les indiqué mais il n'a pas
de mutation
10 de résistance entre guillemets ou
d'échappement vaccinale qui est quand
même notre grande question pour le futur
car a pu y aura autre chose après
lorient delta le seul but le seul
variant qui tient une ébauche
d'échappement vaccinale et le variant
bettal variant sud africain ce n'est pas
le cas du rayon delta donc à plein doses
de vaccins qui sont en partie sud et des
deux vaccins à mérida n'est pas que les
autres également
astrazeneca un tout petit peu moins et
bien les deux doses de vaccin et on vous
avez vu qu'on est passé de 2 ans en
admettant que huit jours ou sept jours
après la deuxième dose il y avait une
réponse immunitaire vaccinale est
effective
campbellton effective il ya une
protection d'une part contre la survenue
de forme grave qu'on éteint quand on est
infecté est une une protection contre la
transmission
alors là aussi il y as mal compréhension
ces vaccins ne protège pas totalement
contre la transmission
ac c'est un concept différent du vaccin
que vous connaissez ils ont une
efficacité à plus de 90% sur la survenue
de forme grave
ils n'ont pas une efficacité à 90% sur
la transmission c'est à dire que vous
pouvez être parfaitement j'en ai un
exemple récent familiale on peut
parfaitement être avoir lu ces deux
vaccins
depuis maintenant trois mois et puis
être contaminés avec le variant delta
qui possède certaines caractéristiques
mais il n'y a pas d'impact
il n'y a pas d'impact pour la personne
elle fait un peu de température
éventuellement revoir même elle reste
symptomatique
donc le niveau de protection pour
répondre à votre question sur la
transmission on les cimes autour d'eux
un peu vrai 70% après les deux accès
après les deux vaccinations
mais je suis drastiquement draps
steek mans après une ce quand il ya eu
une seule vaccination donc sur la
question de dire les vaccinés qui aurait
été qu'ils auraient reçu une seule
vaccination pourrait entrer ensuite
vivre normalement être suivi avec une
pcr tous les dix jours oublier enfin en
tout cas moi je ne valide pas
scientifiquement je suis extrêmement
claires sur ce variant particulier
qu'est le variant delta avec ce niveau
de transmission et bien une seule
vaccination qu'ils s'agisse d'une
vaccination de type m et reina ou de
type astrazeneca c'est différent pour
pour les gens ce n est bien ne suffit
pas à protéger un contre les formes
graves 2 contre la transmission doux en
effet il faut arriver aux deux
vaccinations
alors on peut les rapprocher on peut les
mettre à trois semaines les deux
vaccinations on peut admettre que c'est
une semaine après la deuxième quand les
couverts mais il faut ce type de choses
alors si vous voulez ensuite nuancé bien
sûr qu'on peut nuancer mais à force de
nuances et on on prend pas de décision à
certains moments
si vous avez soit 80 ans votre réponse
immunitaire après une seule une seule
injection à l'est elle est proche de
zéro si vous avez 17 en une seule
injection à 17 ans il ya probablement
une réponse immunitaire plus
significatif qui existe mais on est
incapable de le quantifier donc la règle
est en tout cas à mes yeux et c'était la
même chose au niveau d'un afficheur
qu'on soit bien clair c'est pour cela la
lutte à la fois contre la transmission
et la survenue de formules rap il faut
deux injections
merci pour ces précisions alors on va
prendre cinq sénateurs et ensuite on
fera une deuxième série laurence cohen
la présidente
j'abonde dans le sens de ce qui a été
dit par mes autres collègues sur
effectivement la nécessité d'accentuer
les campagnes d'information pour
convaincre
parce que c'est pédagogique parce que
c'est important et parce que c'est vrai
que ce vaccin est un est encore un
vaccin qui est récent et donc il ya
encore des peurs donc il faut il faut
essayer de les faire reculer le plus le
plus possible moi j'aimerais vous
interrogez professeurs sur le faite vous
l'avez un petit peu dit on constate
quand même que sur l'ensemble du
territoire national
il y à vraiment des inégalités sociales
de santé et que ça au niveau de ces
inégalités et c'est vrai au niveau
d'ailleurs de l'hexagone mais c'est vrai
aussi au niveau 2 des ultramarins de
l'autre mère on n'arrive pas à faire à
faire progresser on va dire la
population pour aller vers vers la
vaccination
donc qu'est ce que vous vous prônez
outre les campagnes effectivement
d'information est ce qu'il ne faut pas
été encore plus intrusif j'allais
presque dire pour aller vers ces
populations au travers de bus au travers
de voile a essayé d'avoir c'est comme
d'ailleurs au niveau de moelle et les
échos g sur les personnels soignants
quand c'est à l'intérieur d'un service
et qu' il ya des vaccinations dans le
service eh bien il n'y a pas de
personnel récalcitrants ont donc il ya
une espèce de d'émulation voilà donc ça
c'est ma première question ma deuxième
question c'est qu'on parle à juste titre
de vaccination c'est très important je
suis d'accord avec vous les deux les
deux injections et cetera
mais est-ce que vous qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire sur l'avancée des
traitements puisqu'il a été quand on en
entend plus parler mais je sais que
l'institut pasteur à lille il ya encore
failli à des recherches là dessus donc
est ce qu'il ya eu un espoir là dessus
et la toute dernière question c'est la
troisième question je suis assez
interrogative et je me demande si ça ne
contrevient pas au serment d'hippocrate
quand je vois dans dans la loi le fait
que sauf cas d'urgence
et bien les personnes qui qui ont des
soins programmés devront pour bénéficier
donc de ses soins programmés dans les
établissements de santé
bénéficiez donc soit d'un test soit d'un
d'un vaccin et c est ce que c'est à dire
qu'on les soigne aurait pas s'il n'avait
pas en face et de ses dents dans la loi
ce que je regarde
est-ce que j'ai bien compris ou est ce
que c'est une mauvaise interprétation de
ma part qu'est ce que vous en pensez
philippe bonnecarrère il merci madame
présidente monsieur brevets soeur
vaccine on vaccine ont bien compris et
qu'elle est
la stratégie à long terme que l'on
raisonne oublier son vaccinale ou pas
sanitaire la politique grecque finale du
pays a été réussie la population et
demain de vacciner est ce que cette
vaccination globale nous protégera pas
dans la durée
est-ce que elle réduit sensiblement
brasse tiquement pour reprendre un de
vos adverbe les risques de voir
apparaître des variants est ce que l'on
pourrait avoir comme le pensent certains
de nos concitoyens
une sorte de rebond des mutations des
variants liés à ce renforcement
vaccinale est ce que vous pourriez nous
projeter un petit peu vers ce long terme
ce processeur alors si rené paul savary
oui merci après l'audition du ministre
monsieur
le président vous vous confortez
véritablement cette stratégie pour
protéger les personnes fragiles les
personnes âgées les personnes à
comorbidités notamment alors qu'est ce
qui vous a poussé à ne pas rendre
obligatoire la vaccination de ces
personnes fragiles puisque vous êtes
maintenant partisans d'une obligation
vaccinale pour les soignants c'est vous
l'avez expliqué c'est tout à fait bien
entendu des arguments convaincants
qu'est ce qui vous pousse à ne pas dire
ou dans un premier temps ben finalement
si ces personnes fragiles et et où le
vaccin en tout cas 90 95 % vacciner on
sait les toucher vous l'avez dit par les
maires par les associations on les
connaît les facteurs les connaissent
l'assurance maladie on connaît un
certain nombre si nous avions fait
véritablement une concentration pour
arriver pas forcément à une obligation
mais les obliger indirectement comme
vous le faites à travers le pain comme
on le fait à travers le pass and i ter à
se faire vacciner
est ce que cette protection qui aurait
garanti une une non surcharge
enfin garanti c'est pas le thermique qui
aurait évité une non surcharge des
services hospitaliers n'aurait pas
entraîné lundi moins de contraintes pour
l'ensemble de notre population
martin lévriers je ne m'y attendais pas
merci madame la présidente
merci monsieur monsieur le président une
question qui est qui rejoint un peu
celle de laurence cohen sur l'accès à
l'hôpital et aux soins pour des
personnes qui qui ne sont pas vaccinés
mais qui doivent continuer à recevoir
des soins à l'hôpital et je les tendres
est aussi à toutes les personnes qui
pourraient arriver à l'hôpital avec des
accompagnants quid et des accompagnants
si on veut garder sanctuary zay
l'hôpital entre guillemets que fait-on
est ce qu on fait faire des tests
immédiat aux personnes qui
accompagnaient ce que on les oblige à se
vacciner est ce que je ne sais pas un
peu toutes ces questions sur le valais
vert et je vous remercie d'avoir d'avoir
abordé ce sujet je me pose aussi une
question qui suit lé l'audition que le
rapporteur a organisé il ya quelques
jours et où les médecins généralistes
ont enfin obtenu le fichier de leurs
patients qui ne se seraient pas ou qui
ne se sont pas vaccinés or l'ordre des
médecins nous a clairement fait
comprendre que c'était très très
compliqué certes isabelle fichiers mais
que en fonction du nombre des doses qui
recevait etc etc bref techniquement ça
devenait très compliqué alors qu'on a le
sentiment a priori que c'est peut-être
le meilleur vecteur le médecin
généraliste pour convaincre ceux qui
sont les plus fragiles et qui ne sont
pas venus alors comment les evs et quel
serait le les bons moyens pour aller
vers les médecins généralistes pour
qu'ils accélèrent cette possibilité ou
qu'on leur donne la possibilité
d'accélérer
je vous remercie alors ok c'est encore
après le professeur delfraissy répondre
à andré reichardt est ensuite alain
milon qui à distance
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
monsieur le professeur vous nous avez
dit tout à l'heure en introduction que
ce variant était plus contagieux 40%
plus contagieux disais vue disiez vous
que
le variant 60 sous part dans 60 alors
précisément
moi j'aimerais avoir quelques
informations complémentaires sur ça nous
avons tout à l'heure auditionné ne sut
le ministre véran qui nous disait que
tout récemment il aurait appris l'année
hitchock la charge virale de ceux de ce
variant serait mille fois mille fois
supérieur donc est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire techniquement scientifiquement
qu'est ce que c'est c'est quoi car 60%
plus contagieux mais une charge virale
mille fois supérieur moi j'avais lu il
n'y a pas tellement longtemps aussi
peut-être ya quatre cinq jours que il
serait ce variant quatre fois plus
contagieux que l'ancien enfin moi
j'aimerais y voir clair
vous avez compris que derrière il y à la
question évidente de certes de la
contagion mais aussi de la dangerosité
bien contagion et dangerosité c'est
naturellement pas la même chose bien
et lorsqu'on l'entend dire mais le se
passe sanitaire c'est quoi ces ccc une
panique de la part du gouvernement
soudain ça repose sur quoi voilà
scientifiquement est ce que vous pouvez
vous avez commencé par ça tout à l'heure
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
parce que pour moi c'est fondamental
ensuite alain milon et le professeur
delfraissy pourra répondre alain milon
et encore plein de questions au point
d'envoyer à d'abord apprendre les
questions de ceux qui n'ont pas parlé
oui mais sinon rien
vous m'entendez
oui oui
monsieur d'abord veuillez agréer
messieurs je ne suis pas en présentiel
et nos agendas sont parfois un peu
compliqué j'aurais peut-être être en
présentiel très surpris par les
auditions en deux gérants surpris par
l'égoïsme le franco français et on est
dans un pays au final membres exigent de
pouvoir se vacciner de pouvoir à se
protéger et à ne rien oublier pour le
faire et on entend donc des discussions
à sanitaires à question elle mettre sa
cible nous sommes dans un pays qui a
cette chance énorme de pouvoir dessiner
mais il y a des pays de à l'extérieur
des frontières de l'europe qui n'ont pas
cette chance
ces pays on ne pouvait signer les
populations des arts aignan vont arriver
et ses vaillants ainsi que d'être comme
vous l'avez dit à est charmant et final
haletant intérêts rapidement et à
vacciner nos populations et à vacciner
les populations des pays qui n'ont pas
les moyens
merci professeur beaucoup de questions
sur laisse répondre alors je vais
démarrer peut-être par la question qui
rejoint celle de l'ami lyon le 6 et de
la question de de la vue d'ensemble où
allons nous parce que c'est à 7,1 des
limites la gestion de crise qui est de
répondre au coup par coup et ne pas
prendre le temps d'avoir une vision
d'ensemble s'est il faut le dire très
compliqué très compliqué parce que ce
virus nous surprend vous avez compris
que c'est lui le maître du jeu ce n'est
ce ne sont ni les scientifiques ni les
politiques
ni les citoyens c'est ce virus qui est
le maître du jeu j'ai connu la même
chose moi au démarrage du du vih c'est
pas que je fasse un élément de
comparaison
mais c'est quand même ça reste la plus
grande pandémie que nous avons jusqu'à
maintenant et aussi on s'est trouvés
pendant des années alors que là on est
en terme de mois et on sait trouver
déséquilibrée dans notre mode de pensée
dans notre mode de fonctionnement
s'ils ont ce procès on tente de se
projeter et je le ferai avec beaucoup de
prudence parce que je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas et c'est pas de moi qui ne sait
pas c'est la communauté scientifique qui
évoque un certain nombre d'hypothèses
mais qui sommes toutes peuvent être que
revécu rebattu d'un d'un revers de main
regardez ce qui s'est passé avec la le
variant uk alpha puis se mariant delta
alors on va avoir bible le variant delta
pendant plusieurs mois et c'est on est
partis j'y reviendrai et que sur les sur
les moyens de lutte indépendamment de la
vaccination
la question qui m'a été posée ensuite
quand on interroge les virologues il y à
2 2 vision un peu une première vision
qui est pour certains d'entre eux de
dire les l'ensemble des mutations qui a
été observée autour de deux de ces
variants elles surviennent quasi en
totalité pas seulement mais en talk dans
la majorité des cas dans la protéine
spike et donc la protéine d'attache du
récepteur et pas sur le reste et pas sur
les autres enzymes les autres les autres
sites de mutation ce qui est important
d'ailleurs pour les médicaments après
donc la capacité intrinsèque de ce virus
a trouvé dans une sorte de modélisation
pour lui même pour tous seuls et et à
muter elle et elle pourrait être limité
et on pourrait aboutir dans un délai qui
estime à 2 lord peut-être d'une année à
avoir un autre variante peut-être et
puis au bout du bout du
ont une forme d'épuisement entre
guillemets de la capacité de mutation et
d'aller donc vers une sorte de deux
variants finale qui serait un variant
qui rentreraient dans le cadre d'un
coronavirus usuelles et donc de qui se
banaliserait entre guillemets ça c'est
la vision optimiste il ya une vision qui
est moins optimiste qui est qui est de
dire oui mais jusqu'à maintenant comme
je voulais expliqué on a eu des variants
qui touché des zones de la spike qui
faisait qu' il était plus transmissible
mais on n'a rien eu sur ou pas grand
chose sur des variants plus grave et on
n'a pas eu de choses non plus sur des
zones qui seraient des zones impliquées
dans des phénomènes d'échappement
immunitaire c'est-à-dire qui sous une
pression de sélection exercés soit pour
l'immunité populationnelle qui est qui
existe dans une population qui a déjà
été touchée par une balle prenait
variant où sous la pression de sélection
des vaccins qui pourrait faire que on
sélectionne entre guillemets au fur et à
mesure qu'on a une vaccination forte
mais insuffisante
on sélectionne l'apparition de mutants
qui pourrait aller vers d'échappement et
militaire comme je voulais indiqué tout
à l'heure le variant sud africain est le
seul qui n'est pas un variant de
d'échappement et militaires mais qui en
a certaines caractéristiques qui fait
qu'on sait que par exemple sur le varié
en bêta et bien l'efficacité des vaccins
dont on parlait tout à l'heure elle est
moindre elles aient diminué d'au moins
30 à 40% sur ce variant bêta donc sur
une sur cette vision d'ensemble
on va on risque d'avoir après le variant
delta un autre variante dans le courant
de
de l'hiver ou du printemps 2022 pour
lequel on a probablement le plus de
chances qu'il soit toujours sensible aux
modèles de vaccination que nous avons
maintenant et on commencera à voir ce
moment là si on a je dirais dans
l'hypothèse moins optimiste une
l'apparition d'un variant de deux
mutations d'échappement immunitaire en
sachant que si c'était le cas silence
hymne progresse et on a maintenant les
capacités de refaire aussi vous le savez
des nouveaux vaccins dirigés contre ces
variants qui pourraient des variants
d'échappement donc voilà alors sur une
stratégie d'ensemble moi je crois qu' on
est parti sur quelque chose de long 2 2
mais de longs à fond on est là en train
de discuter du delta en fin juillet
parce que ça nous prend tous et on peut
comprendre que ses clés qui un élément
inquiétant j'ai démarré part ça tout à
l'heure mais il faut qu'on se parle avec
une vision de long terme même si je sais
que c'est difficile en temps le seul
point je dirais de 2,2 pour les
populations s'est dit bien d'aboutir à
une couverture vaccinale ou liées à
l'infection qui soit proche de 95 %
alors ensuite c'est deuxième question
toujours dans cet aspect là ça veut dire
quoi 1 60% de plus de transmissions
alors ça veut dire quoi en effet plus de
transmission est ce qu'il a et une
anomalie sur son récepteur qui fait
qu'il accroche plus est ce que il
remplit plus est en effet des données
récentes montrent qu'il ya deux choses
d'abord il ya plus de virus pour les
gens qui sont infectés il ya une
capacité sécrétions qui est plus
importante
et deuxièmement elle paraît légèrement
plus durable donc on a deux éléments qui
poussent et qui explique entre
guillemets qu' il ne s'agit pas d'une
mutation qui lui permettrait de
s'accrocher mieux sur le récepteur
mais c'est qu'il a une capacité de
multiplication qui est plus forte
je vous ai répondu c'est bien en
biologie si l'on reprend la biologie
parce que ce variant se multiplient plus
et plus vite qu'il est plus
transmissible
je termine sur les blés les
considérations générales pour les
questions de 20 millions sur sur le
leurre sud bien sûr cette année alors
c'est ça et ça doit rentrer dans une
vision stratégique général on va se
retrouver à la fin de l'hiver 2021 2022
avec 40 pays du monde riches qui vont
être vaccinés à 90 % voire plus dans
dans certains pays et avec le reste du
monde
très peu vaccinés alors le reste du
monde très peu vaccinés
c'est une population beaucoup plus jeune
ça n'a strictement rien à voir ils sont
dans des conditions géographiques et
également d'urbanisation qui sont très
différentes et où ça et qu'on a encore
plein d'inconnues pourquoi certains pays
n'ont pas été touchés il ya encore un
certain nombre de points d'inconnues sur
ce qui s'est passé en particulier en
afrique au sens très large du terme
en dehors de l'afrique du sud c'est une
des vraies questions mais sur la vision
globale que vous évoquez qu'au nom dont
la gestion de long terme de cette crise
on va gérer 40 pays riches vacciner
capable de faire des
d'avoir accès à des vaccins dirigés
contre les variants de mutation et puis
comment le reste du monde
eh bien tu seras trés incomplètement
vaccinés
les dernières données de le ms suggère
que il y aura pas de vaccination
générale avant 2023 2024 va et encore
c'est totalement optimiste je pense donc
c'est comment on va gérer ces deux
mondes
est-ce qu'on va se bloquer dans nos 40
pays ses proches n'ont pas une solution
vous avez vu que les pays qui ont choisi
0 que vides de type australie de tweets
nouvelle zélande sont dans des
situations extrêmement difficiles de
l'amateur dire qu'ils vont bien mais il
referma cents à 100 cas et en refermant
à 100 cas il referme le pays et
l'australie et dans cette stratégie là
mais est ce que c'est une solution
on a en a choisi une autre sur
l'échappement et comme ils ont pas
vaccinés et se trouve à 12 pour cent
blessés on oublie de le dire mais des
grands pays que l'on choisit qui en
choisit le zéro comme ils se sont mis
dans des situations où ils ont pris du
retard sur la vaccination et où donc ils
sont obligés de refermer de refermer
complètement et donc c'est pas la
solution qu'on peut choisir en europe
par pour des raisons évidemment
géographie donc voilà la vision globale
excusez moi j'étais un peu long mais
c'est vrai qu'on a rarement le
l'occasion d'en discuter de prendre la
main pour une vision globale mais en
sachant que c'est très difficile parce
que je conçois que la population
d'attentes vis d'entendre ce que je vous
ai dit ce matin que le politique non
plus au sens très large du terme c'est
pas c'est pas spécialement réjouissant
mais inversement
eh bien je crois qu'on est à 18 mois de
cette crise il faut quand même qu'on ait
une vision de plus long terme et pas
uniquement une vision de réponse
immédiate à chaque fois et qu'on ait une
vision de plus long terme est bien la
vision de plus long terme je viens de
vous en donner quelques éléments ce
matin alors sur des questions plus plus
précise la protection des personnes plus
fragiles bah écoutez je vous ai répondu
c'est moi j'ai la même vision que vous
cessez cette carte entre précarité et
risque des collines hésitation vaccinale
donc c'est vraiment aller vers
et c'est aller vers pas dans du top down
c'est pas une décision politique c'est
pas une décision des médecins
c'est une décision de il faut s'appuyer
sur ce qu'on a de très riches en france
les mairies le milieu associatif les
tissus locaux c'est le moment un
plongeon de dents c'est le moment de les
mettre à bord et et docks et c'est eux
qui pourront expliquer à ces populations
les plus complexes
les médecins généralistes oui alors sauf
qu'on est dans un moment un peu
compliqué les médecins généralistes ils
sont ils sont comme tout le monde il a
envie de prendre quelques vacances et la
réponse est là et la crise est elle est
là pour pour le delta donc il ya premier
message pour les médecins j'ai appelé le
président du conseil de l'ordre hier et
je lui ai dit je lui dis je pense que
vos troupes n'ont pas encore compris ce
qu'est l'être l'impact du variant delta
là pendant les semaines qui viennent que
les médecins généralistes n'ont pas
compris la rapidité avec laquelle était
en train d'arriver ce variant est donc
en effet il faut il faut qu'il le
comprenne bien et ça va rejoindre une
des questions sur les sur les
traitements que vous m'avez posée alors
sur les autres questions à les verts
sont nés répondu les traitements alors
les traitements c'est un élément
fondamental pour la suite
ne comptez pas sur les traitements là
pour pour lutter contre la quatrième
vague de delta vous savez qu'on a deux
types de traitement c'est-à-dire lui
c'est l'idée d'utiliser des antiviraux
de façon extrêmement précoce pour avoir
une stratégie de test and treat
vous avez des premiers signes vous êtes
testé en boutre est tout de suite c'est
à dire c'est du traitement à j-3 entre
j3 et j5 et que vous soyez à risque ou
pas à risque on vous traite tout de
suite alors pour le faire on a des
anticorps monoclonaux qui sont qui sont
dirigées contre des éléments de de la
protéine spike
qu'il faut utiliser en combinaison et
qui sont et qui dès qu'ils sont
utilisables par voie intraveineuse
c'est à dire que ça oblige à passer par
un système un peu lourd d'avoir un
impact avec le système de soins
actuellement il ya 2500 patients france
qui ont été traités par ces anticorps
monoclonaux donc vous voyez que ses
pilotes et et que c'est pas ça qui va
nous permettre de répondre à une vague
très importante en traitant les
personnages puisque on pourrait imaginer
vous avez plus de 60 ans vous n'avez pas
été vaccinés pour des raisons diverses
vous êtes obèse vous avez 45 ans vous
n'avez pas été vaccinés immédiatement on
vous traite avec ce type de traitement
on va essayer de le faire j'en parlais
avec eux le professeur nisand ps
d'antona hier soir tard pour essayer de
monter ça là encore de prendre une
vitesse supérieure là pendant les
semaines et mois d'août pour le mettre
en place
mais je n'y crois pas trop en termes de
faisabilité
là où j'y crois c'est plus pour la fin
de l'année où nous aurons des antiviraux
qui seront par voie orale
c'est à dire sous forme de comprimés et
où la stratégie de deux de test and
treat la même un peu peut éventuellement
son visage et c'est à dire que vous avez
des premiers symptômes vous êtes testez
vous prenez des comprimés pendant cinq
jours ci à une réduction de passage aux
formes sévères aux formes graves chez
les non vaccinés et j'entends bien et
bien euros ça serait une des solutions
mais il ya plusieurs compagnies qu'ils
sentent qu'ils fabriquent ce type et qui
pensent et qui sont en essai avec ce
type de molécules je vous rappelle que
c'était la stratégie initiale complète
tout à fait au départ souvenez vous du
mois de mars 2020 avec d'autres produits
sur lequel je reviendrai pas mais l'idée
en soi n'était pas idiot tu as tu as
entre 8
moi j'y crois on l'a on l'a on l'a fait
dans d'autres dont d'autres stratégies
mais n'y comptez pas nous n'aurons pas
les moyens de le faire parce que nous
n'avons pas les éléments pour le faire
pour répondre à aux variants delta on
aura les éléments de le faire pour le
pour le pour la fin de l'année et ça
revient à la biologie tout à l'heure
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'un
certain nombre de ces molécules ne sont
pas dirigées contre les protéines de
l'aspai c'est à dire celle qui mute
mais contre des protéines intrinsèque du
virus qui l'aide à se fabriquer en
particulier la protéine la protéase et
qui donc ne sont pas touchés ces
molécules serait possiblement efficace
contre des variants stratégie long terme
les soins programmés alors écoutez moi
là je je je dis joker parce que j'ai pu
j'ai pas regardé dans le détail le
médecin que je suis ne peut que vous
suivrez se s'interroger
je ne crois pas ou je crois que c'est
une mauvaise peut-être terminologie de
la loi mais vous avez raison évidemment
c'est votre rôle de le souligner la
priorité c'est le soin aux patients
enfin cgg aucun doute là dessus alors
ensuite qu'on vérifie dans un contexte
de circulation virale très élevé si ces
patients sains sont vaccinés qu'on leur
pose la question quand je vois des gens
aux consultations dans 2 2 pour d'autres
pathologies je leur dis est-ce que vous
avez été vacciné je leur pose la
question
c'est une question actuelle de médecins
bon deuxièmement si sont pas vaccinés et
pour pour je dirais programme et enfin
aimé savoir ce qu'on va faire
leur dire est ce que vous avez fait un
test et leurs demandes émanent de faire
un test par exemple pour quelqu'un qui
revient en hôpital de jour tous les
quinze jours et bien de refaire un tel
6-2 s'il ne rentre pas dans la stratégie
de vaccination m'apparaît normal mais
c'est pas du refus de soins enfin faut
surtout pas rentrer là dedans il faut
profondément respecté dans une certaine
mesure et essayer de comprendre
l'hésitation vaccinale je suis pour
aller vers ce même se donner tous les
moyens on les respectant il ya des
choses profondes derrière il ya une
minorité qui est qui est très fragilisé
par cette notion de vaccins et bien le
médecin que je suis dit bien sûr qu'il
faut pousser mais il faut le respecter
dans une certaine mesure et entamer le
dialogue avec eux je crois que j'ai
répondu à peu près tout
précision oui ces professeurs j'ai à peu
près compris excusez moi d'être long à
la détente
là la différence entre la contagion et
la charge virale à peu près vous n'avez
pas répondu sur la dangereux exacte tout
à fait non tout à fait c'est pas répondu
sur deux points la dangerosité et puis
une autre question les sujets les plus
âgés par rapport aux plus jeunes excusez
moi alors sur sur la dangerosité
les données que nous avons montrent que
le variant delta pour l'instant ne
semble pas plus dangereux je dis bien
pour l'instant
parce que on a eu exactement la même
vision sur le variant uk autour du 20
décembre
je m'en souviens très bien on était en
dialogue avec lequel l'anglais et où on
allait on avait tout de suite perçu que
l'on était en train de changer là la
donne avec ce brillant uk mais
initialement on a pensé jusqu'à
pratiquement jusqu'au 20 janvier à
moissy semaine de décalage pour montrer
pour avoir des arguments montrant qu'ils
habitent dangerosité accrue
actuellement je pense que le ministre a
dû vous le donner il ya un seul papier
qui est un papier des équipes écossaises
que j'avais là tout à l'heure d'ailleurs
en col et je désirais interrogé
là-dessus parce que c'est évidemment une
question fondamentale
je suis pas totalement convaincu par le
fait que ce variant à une dangerosité
accrue sa dangerosité
elle est liée au fait qu'il est plus
transmissible et ça suffit ça suffit
pour nous tous sens sur lui quand mais
il n'a pu n'entraînent pas plus de
formes graves chez les gens qui l'attend
mais si ça se trouve et alors là je vais
faire vraiment je vous le bilan
il faut être très humble vis-à-vis des
connaissances scientifiques et je dis
pas ça du tout pour me couvrir
j'en ai rien à faire je le dis parce que
je le pense
c'est à dire que on avance en marche
sur les connaissances sur ce virus il ya
des choses qui au fur à mesure on
aimerait pouvoir dire qu'on s'est tous
et la réponse est non il ya des choses
qu'on sait et les choses qu'on peut
prévoir et il ya des choses sur
lesquelles on apprend et c'est logique
avec ce nouveau variant alors sur la
dernière question sur les populations
les plus fragiles par rapport aux
population générale c'est ça ça va ce
sujet sur lequel j'ai déjà donné il ya
de nombreux mois y compris dans cette
instance en disant que bon voilà c'est
de cette puce est virus toucher les
populations les plus fragiles et il
fallait évidemment protéger si possible
les plus fragiles bien sûr c'est la
priorité pour la vaccination
alors c'est pas nul a en france celui
qu'on a un retard en france par rapport
à d'autres pays européens sur le niveau
de vaccination et en particulier les
populations les plus fragiles on l'a si
on l'est on l'a signalé même si c'est
parfois difficile un peu à lire mais on
l'a signalé dans notre dans notre avis
d'ici juillet quand on fait quand on
regarde où compris par rapport à
l'angleterre mais aussi aux nederland
par rapport à l'allemagne et puis par
contre on est un peu près le même niveau
pour ça que que l'espagne et et que
l'italie sur les populations les plus
fragiles 10 % des plus de 60 ans mais
aussi ai-je 1,6 beaucoup là dessus sur
et s'en sort sans effet 200 exercices et
enfin est ce le soupèse mes mots là le
deuxième grand facteur de risque
d'obésité
c'est le deuxième rang fecteau d'elle
vous avez tous vu il ya quinze jours
-les enquête sur masi t en france 17%
17% avec un imc supérieur à 30
la france étant et puis par ailleurs on
a eu notre population française celle en
quête de havre de hier ou avant-hier où
les femmes françaises sont les plus
minces du monde au niveau européen en
plus qu'un bon et ça montre via et alors
et alors
d'ailleurs je ferai pas de commentaire
dans cette danse est noble assemblée
mais c'est pour vous montrer que
justement on à l'extrême c'est à dire
qu'on a on a le 17 pour cent avec
surcharge pondérale qui est un risque
très important de formes sévères ou de
formes graves et qu'il a n'est pas est
indépendant de l'âge nous donc cette
population 17% fait le calcul ou même et
on estime avec beaucoup d'incertitudes
s'il y aurait seulement 55 % des
patients en surcharge pondérale qui
seraient vaccinés donc ça laisse un
réservoir d'accès pour le virus qui dans
un premier temps ça va répondre à votre
question dans un premier temps si on va
vers et ccp des populations défavorisées
si on va vers c'est évidemment la
première cible c'est protéger les plus
fragiles à des niveaux divers mais de
toute façon à un moment donné et c'est
ce qu'on risque de voir par exemple chez
les plus jeunes à partir du mois de
septembre et la rentrée scolaire
il va y avoir un tel niveau de
circulation du virus que il ya forcément
un impact y compris s'ils ont laissé ce
féru circulait donc la priorité en terme
de stratégie sur le système de soins
c'est de vacciner les populations les
plus fragiles et les plus et les plus
âgés qui et c'est là on peut être le
plus convaincant plus me semble-t-il
mais dans le même temps il faut aller
aussi vers une verrine vaccination plus
générale pour les raisons qu'on a
indiqué donc c'est pas contradictoire
mais c'est avec deux objectifs qui sont
différents mais c'était pas tout à fait
ma question il ya eu un choix d'
obligation vaccinale pour les soignants
et deux passes sanitaire que je
comprends tout à fait bien pourquoi ne
pas avoir choisi de protéger notamment
les personnes les plus âgées
c'était ça c'est un choix
un choix vous avez sûrement une raison
qui a fait que se faisait plutôt dans le
choix que vous avez exposé alors moi je
reviens au débat initial sur
l'obligation vaccinale j'ai fait plus
que depuis le début je suis plutôt en
retrait sur la notion générale d'
obligation vaccinale
je vous ai indiqué que j'avais changé
j'avais cheminer sur le problème des
soignants parce que on est là dans une
activité professionnelle ça fait partie
intrinsèque et les soignants de autour
de cette table
ça fait partie intrinsèque de notre
métier je considère que c'est c'est très
clair après le reste c'est on est bien
dans de la protection de populations qui
sont plus à risque que d'autres
je pense fondamentalement qu'en terme de
santé publique et de décisions de santé
publique
eh bien il faut finir de les convaincre
entre guillemets parce que nous
n'arriverons pas nous n'arrivons pas à
faire passer un message d' obligation
vaccinale et ça va être vous voyez déjà
les les
les tensions qui sont en train de
s'exercer à propos de ce pass sanitaire
avec des modalités qui restent à définir
mais voyez déjà les tensions qui peut y
avoir sur une sur une prise de position
de billets au niveau obligations et
final je pense que ça sera contre
productif bon puis après dans cette
crise il faut il faut il faut partir de
l'idée qu'il faut savoir être évolutif
et donc voila voila ma position
en tout cas à ce 22 juillet 2021 alors
on a encore des questions nathalie
goulet rapidement lewis et le professeur
je crois vous avez partiellement répondu
la première question c'était sur les
délais entre deux vaccinations de façon
à pouvoir avoir une couverture plus
rapide avec avec cette vaccination qui
est ce qu on a changé les délais entre
les
deux injections parce que notamment
l'asra zeneca c'était assez long est ce
que est ce que maintenant on a des on a
changé ce ce délai entre les deux
vaccinations et deuxièmement quel est
votre avis sur les femmes enceintes
vernet guillotin oui j'ai deux questions
très rapide concernant le la
contagiosité est le fait alors le
variant la la mutation antécédentes le
premier variant n'avait dit que sur les
terrasses il était possible d'avoir en
laissant de la distanciation voilà de
redonner c'est en extérieur une plus
grande liberté qu'en intérieur
aujourd'hui l'obligation du pass
vaccinale va s'imposer à l'intérieur
comme à l'extérieur est ce que
scientifiquement s'est fondée que le
voilà que le contagiosité en extérieur
sur les terrasses et aujourd'hui
importante avec ce variant delta ça
c'était ma première question et enfin
concernant la troisième dose est ce
qu'il y à des avancées plus précise
également posé sur des données
scientifiques sur une éventuelle
troisième dose à quel moment et pour
toute la population ou pour les plus
fragiles seulement et puis j'avais une
question sur l'adaptation vaccinale mais
vous y avez répondu donc je la poserai
pas merci victoire jasmin merci madame
la présidente monsieur le professeur
merci pour la réponse mesurée que vous
nous donnez et j'apprécie certaines de
vos réponses
pour autant je voudrais vous parler
lelos maximales allant sur mon
territoire et ya pas forcément doses
vaccinales alors les personnes qui ne
souhaitent pas prendre les vaccins arn
arn messagers n'ont pas eu beaucoup de
possibilités contrairement à d'autres
endroits sur le territoire national la
première chose d'autre part on ne peut
pas passer sous silence
quand on fait une certaine bibliographie
que certains de vos confrères qui sont
des chercheurs français qui sont des
sommités qui entrent un à ibb et aussi
sur le vih qui sont très bien connus et
mettent un certain nombre de réserves
alors qu'est ce que vous avez à dire
pour rassurer les gens et la dernière
question c'est concernant la tragédie
qu'a par exemple parce qu'il ya des
vaccins qui ne sont pas arn qui ne sont
pas aussi mis en valeur et promus alors
concernant l'assassinât et peut-être
même les jeunes scène pourquoi
et puisqu'il y a eu des cas de thrombose
pourquoi on ne ferait pas des bilans
préventif justement pour anticiper en
tout cas les éventuelles conséquences et
les effets et désirable connu désormais
notamment sur un truc pour trombine en
fait vous savez mieux comment vous êtes
médecin
donc pour ce sont mes questions et je
voudrais savoir pourquoi en guadeloupe
par exemple le vaccin semble penser le
nombre de public là on a bien identifié
qui devrait en principe les prendre mais
ils y allaient vaccinodromes on ne fait
pas de propositions en fonction de l'âge
et de la diversité des personnes qui
souhaiteraient se faire vacciner
je vous remercie un échec même
oui mais c'est présidente un certain
nombre de question a déjà été posée mais
j'en aurais quand même encore vous avez
par les professeurs du taux d'anticorps
en disant qu'on était incapable de les
quantifier si j'ai bien compris comment
à partir de là on peut faire une vision
avoir une vision à long terme
que pensez-vous des vaccinations
sûrement annuel est ce qu'il faut déjà
propos préparer la population à cette
idée là puisqu'on voit que la
vaccination a du mal à s'implanter
est ce qu'on a toujours il me semble que
les hommes étaient plus fragiles que les
femmes à ce virus
est-ce que c'est toujours est ce que tu
es c'est toujours vrai et la dernière
chose tout ce qui est fait pour
l'instant si bien la vaccination que le
pass sanitaires c'est beaucoup dans
l'objectif de ne pas avoir confiné enfin
de mâcon soit l'automne si malgré tout
on était obligé d'y aller
comment est-ce que ça se passerait pour
les personnes qui ont déjà été vaccinées
puisque on pousse au maximum
et puis comment est ce que ça pourrait
être compris au niveau de la population
d'avoir un re confinement éventuellement
partiel c'est en tout cas ce que
l'allemagne envisagerait de faire si mes
infos sont exactes le groupe
merci madame la présidente monsieur
professeur je remercie vraiment pour ce
que vous avez dit parce que je partage
totalement cette idée qu'il faut
convaincre plutôt que d'imposer et
comprendre l'hésitation vaccinale et ça
envoie la question de la communication
parce que ça a été évoqué plusieurs fois
on est tous d'accord sur le principe
qu'il faudrait peut-être communiquer
plus mais moi je ne suis pas convaincu
par le contenu de la communication qu'on
a vu jusqu'à présent
alors ces derniers temps je n'ai pas
trop regardé la télévision
c'est face il ya des nouveaux spots mais
les spots qu'on a eus récemment général
il amené l'idée qu'on allait pouvoir de
nouveau ce faire les petits câlins ou
retourner aux sports ou faire des trucs
sympas mais finalement on se trouve
quand même devant des gens qui ont plus
peur maintenant du vaccin que de la
maladie et est-ce qu'il faut pas
envisager je sais que ce serait
peut-être malsain de faire plus peur que
la peur mais malgré tout se poser cette
question est un peu plus cash on l'a
fait pour le le cancer du poumon moi
j'ai lire j'aime afic et infirmières en
ehpad qui m'a dit ceux qui se refusent
de se faire vacciner ils ont jamais vu
les yeux d'une personne en détresse
respiratoire
donc sans aller trop loin est ce qu'il
faut pas quand même avoir une
communication qui soit un petit peu plus
calme franches voilà je vous remercie
merci et je rajouterais une question
comme un voeu commun transmises notre
collègue raymond tout c'est moche qui
qui a dû partir quel est le bénéfice
risque pour les 12 17 ans le délai de
vaccination écoutez on a essayé de le
réduire au maximum tout en s'appuyant
enfin sur des données scientifiques les
plus solides et je vous ai indiqué tout
à l'heure qu'il fallait vraiment qu'on
fasse attention avec ce variant delta en
raison du niveau de transmission etc en
particulier après une seule vaccination
de type m rna il n'y avait pas de
protection je suis très ferme là dessus
le deuxième élément je vous parle
évidemment de vaccination qu'on les
choses aussi soit clair il ya un comité
d'orientation vaccinale qui est dirigée
par alain fischer dont on sait plus la
fonction que que la mienne on se parle
tous les jours
1 on se parle tous les jours donc je
vais être amené à parler d'un peu de
vaccins plus que je ne l'aurais souhaité
peut-être mais c'est sachez que on est
très liée et on sauve de la même façon
que je lui donne toutes les informations
sur les variantes et que tout ça est
très très fluide en jeu je tiens à le
dire alors sur le délit de vaccination
donc on est entre deux vaccins mais
reina on répondait à trois semaines et
ensuite ont découvert
une semaine après la deuxième injection
donc quelqu'un qui se fait vacciner là
maintenant il a une deuxième vaccination
trois semaines après il est couvert une
semaine après donc c'est un bras sur le
versant extra zeneca dont la couverture
dont la d'efficacité est un peu moins
bonne que l'évêque saint omer et
n'assure sur les variantes sur le jardin
en delta les délais de vaccination la
intrinsèque à ases-cc et contenu dans le
vaccin
les délais entre la première injection
et la deuxième injection reste long il
reste le plus long que ce que je viens
de vous indiquer donc dans une stratégie
entre guillemets je dirais
d'accélération de la vaccination pour
avoir une couverture à l'automne la
vaccination va pas changer énormément la
donne ou j'avais bien compris
pour répondre à la halle à la quatrième
vague la fin août 1 ont détourné ont
bien trop juste là maintenant c'est trop
mais on est là en train de se projeter
plus tôt pour le mois de septembre
et bien c'est assez logique qu'on aille
vers des vaccins est mais reina en
raison des délais que je viens de vous
indiquer ses du délai c'est pas du choix
de femmes enceintes les recommandations
américaines jusqu'à il ya une semaine
était posé un point d'interrogation sur
le premier trimestre de grossesse
le conseil d'orientation vaccinale a
émis un avis il ya deux ou trois jours à
s'appuyant aussi après discussion avec
nos collègues du sénat et sur l'a fait
avec alain sur le fait qu'on pouvait il
n'y avait pas de contre indication à
vacciner les femmes enceintes durant le
premier trimestre je répète il n'y avait
pas de contre indication à vacciner et
femmes enceintes durant le premier
trimestre alors femmes allaitantes s'il
est si la femme par exemple a été
vaccinées durant le cinquième ou le
sixième
le sixième mois belle à des anticorps
qui vont passer qui vont passer au cours
de la lactation au cours si vous me
posez la question de quelqu'un qui
serait va qui n'auraient pas été
vaccinés qui viendraient d'accoucher et
qu'il faudrait vacciner
eh bien je dis joker je vais réfléchir
et je vous enverrai la réponse sur le le
pass vaccinale est est-ce que ça répond
la question d'une transmission externe
alors moi je voudrais juste m'arrêter un
instant pour vous dire que on a beaucoup
de parler de vaccination du pass
vaccinale est d'aller vers le pur pour
la vaccination
oui mais ça ne va pas changer
fondamentalement la réponse à la
quatrième vague là dans les semaines qui
viennent
la réponse à la quatrième vague elle et
elle va s'appuyer sur une augmentation
de la vaccination et aurez vous voyez
que les délais sont sont là et elle va
s'appuyer sur l'utilisation du pass
sanitaire dans le délai dans lequel il
va se mettre en place et avec des
modalités qui ne relève pas de ma
compétence
mais elle va s'appuyer aussi sur ou
est-ce qu'on se contaminent sur revenir
aux gestes barrières simple
individuelles qui ont totalement
exploser totalement expression moi si je
vous pose la question de combien de fois
par jour en ce moment vous êtes en train
de vous laver les mains avec ça je
préfère pas entendre les réponses
vous avez oublié ça moi aussi un peu
aussi un peu on cela beaucoup moins les
mains qu'avant mais c'est très bien si
vous le faites en permanence et la
population générale on le sait
on le fait beaucoup moins les gestes
barrières sur le port du masque c'est
compliqué je le sais dans une phase 2 de
très hautes niveau de contamination
telle qu'on va l'être à partir de dons
les déjà maintenant mais tel qu'on va
l'être encore plus à partir de début
août le report du masque entre
guillemets y compris chez les gens
vaccinés puisque je vous ai dit qu'on
pouvait quand même être être infecté
entre guillemets mais sans formes graves
et quelque chose qui est saint pierre
qui touchent pas quand même
fondamentalement libertés républicaines
le porte je souvenez-vous le port du
masque ya eu aussi beaucoup de
discussions sur le port du masque
d'abord la compréhension de ce que ça
voulait dire
mais finalement il ya une acceptation
qui s'est faite et elle continue à se
faire dans les transports parisiens bon
et ailleurs je ne parle pas et qu'une
part il sauf que je suis à paris comme
en mai et donc les petits gestes au
niveau individuel vont être fondamentaux
pour notre population durant les
semaines qui viennent et ce n'est pas
que le vaccin les mêmes choses on sait
on se contaminent les lepic lac est
absolument très très fort qui a lieu on
neverland et aussi dans la région nord
de l'allemagne
ces lycées liées aux boîtes de nuit moi
j'y peux rien j'ai rien contre les
boîtes de nuit 1
mais c'est une réalité que ce sont des
endroits fermés où on crie on chante on
boit et on perd des gestes de
dispensation sociale les clusters sont
utiles à l'impact du l'impact des
matches de foot et de la coupe d'europe
de foot qui commence à se voir en ce
moment en angleterre il est pas lié
tellement match
il est lié en fait dans les rencontres
dans les anglais nous le raconter très
bien ils vont le publier dans les bus où
on crie ou en chantre et dans les pubs
après c'est à dire je voudrais insister
parce que c'est un peu solennel ici je
voudrais insister que dans les semaines
qui viennent
notre capacité non pas arrêter la vague
mais a limité l'impact sur le système de
soins
il est entre nos mains il est entre les
mains de nos concitoyens et c'est pas
seulement se dire c'est le pass
sanitaires ou c'est le vaccin c'est
aussi les petites mesures oui clairement
on peut s'infecter avec ce lieu à
l'extérieur c'est à dire qu'il faut
reprendre des mesures de précaution
quand on est en extérieur très chaud
mais j'ai un jeu direct avec des mesures
d'existence iations qui sont pas
possibles
ensuite le taux d'anticorps
alors non là j'ai pas bien compris votre
question on peut mesurer le taux
d'anticorps ce qui permet de dire que
quelqu'un était infectée ou pas on a pas
actuellement de bons marqueurs si ce
niveau d'anticorps et un est un niveau
qui est un niveau de protection on n'a
pas de marqueurs de protection et de
corée la de protection soit après
l'infection soit après après vaccination
je vous rappelle que par ailleurs dans
l'humilité de ce contre ce virus
il ya à la fois des anticorps et une
immunité de type t qui n'est pas mesurée
en pratique courante à dire qu'il ya une
double il ya une double immunité qui
peut jouer un rôle
ce taux d'anticorps il est important
parce qu'il permet de se situer à quel
niveau de vaccination de deux sections
se situe je rappelle qu'en france c'est
tres est hétérogène m'enfin en gros
c'est autour de 20 % ou de 2 22% des
gens ayant déjà fait une injection à que
vides mais le problème c'est que dans ce
chiffre il ya tout c'est à dire il ya
des gens qui ont faim que vides au mois
de mars 2020 il ya ce qu'on fait un
qu'ovide au mois de septembre
il ya ce qu'on fait un que lui deux mois
de descendre et tous ceux là ont des
anticorps qui n'était pas dirigée du
tout contre le le variant uk nique entre
le verrions delta donc le le niveau de
protection de ces anticorps il est très
faible et donc les gens qui lisent mais
moi j'ai été infectées je n'ai pas
besoin de me vacciner ils ont faussé
fossiles et évitement ses terres qu'ils
ne sont pas protégés parce que les
anticorps
qu'ils ont produit lors de l'infection
par le virus initial ne les protège pas
contre le variant delta actuelle donc il
faut qu'ils aient bien une injection de
vaccination la communication écoutez
j'ai pas de commentaire parce que je
suis à la recherche de deux leçons de
cours de communication peu d'enjeu vous
avez raison probablement il faut il faut
qu'on modifie
moi je crois beaucoup je vous ai déjà
insisté là-dessus à aller vers le local
à aller vers les messages généraux des
politiques médico-scientifique nos
concitoyens ont donc jusqu'à et voilà
son moi je me sens coupable comme les
autres comment comment mieux approcher
ça bon est ce qu'il faut faire peur j'en
suis pas sûr j'en suis pas sûr du tout
moi mais dire la vérité essayer de dire
la vérité dire ce qu on sait ce qu'on ne
sait pas pouvoir dialoguer autour des
vaccins d' levé élevé un certain nombre
de doses alors madame vous posiez la
question sur finalement les outre-mer et
sur mes chers collègues qui raconte que
le vaccin savent appartement alors sur
les sur les outre mer écoutez on a
beaucoup insisté moi c'est un sujet qui
me tient énormément à coeur sur les
outre-mer parce que ce sont des ce sont
des citoyens français comme les autres
et ils ont ils vont être touchés plus
que les autres le niveau de vaccination
est très faible
la guyane étant le summum je pense que
et c'est d'ailleurs nous avons bon pou
c'est plutôt les autorités à prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu plus
difficile en outre-mer parce que je
pense que la vague en outre-mer va être
très difficile à gérer
et donc il ya un effort de communication
très important il accueillit en est un
pays que je connais bien parce qu'on a
eu le même problème sur les mesures de
prévention sur le vih et s'est très
c'est compliqué ne doit pas baisser les
bras et il doit y avoir un certain
nombre d'arguments qui doivent pouvoir
être déclinée et on voit bien d'ailleurs
dans d'autres régions le niveau de
vaccination est en train est en train de
monter alors sur les collectes qui qui
qui remettent en cause les problèmes
actions chez moi j'ai rien à dire si
vous voulez cesser bien sûr que ce sont
des gens de connu et qui ont fait de
très belles choses dans leur vie et puis
ça m'arrivera peut-être un jour il faut
un moment donné aussi s'arrêter et
ou est ce que vous vous rendez compte
que c'est une chance extraordinaire
d'avoir des vaccins aussi puissant en
peu de temps
si on n'avait pas les vaccins et dans
quelle situation se trouverait parle pas
seulement en france qu'une vision très
générale en europe aux états unis etc
c'est quand même ça qui qui va dans une
certaine mesure ralentir finalement
l'impact sur ça c'est si j'étais dans la
même salle sans vaccin aujourd'hui je
garantis qu'on serait dans une autre
attitude
donc est ce qu'il ya des effets
secondaires des vaccins
réponse oui il y a des effets
secondaires des vaccins est ce qu'on a
et on les connaît mais ils sont très
limités est-ce qu'on a une vision de
long terme de ces vaccins arn non on n'a
pas de vision long terme de ces vaccins
et rennes est-ce que la rn s'intègre
dans notre dna non la rn ne s'intègre
pas dans l'indiana j'ai fait réunir une
commission de biologistes moléculaires
qui avait rien à voir avec les vaccins
pour discuter à fond de ce sujet et la
réponse est claire c'est non ça
s'intègre pas est-ce qu'on a une vision
de long terme
ah non on n'a pas de vision de long
terme est ce que quand vous êtes comme
vous êtes avec un traitement
les nouvelles immunothérapie dans le
cancer à ce que les gens qui ont démarré
il y avait une vision dans le long terme
est-ce que les gens qui démarrait avec
les laiteries thérapie avec les
inhibiteurs de protéase et les
combinaisons ce qu'ils habitent dans une
vision de long terme
non est ce qu'il y avait des effets
secondaires de ces traitements oui donc
bien sûr quelques il y aura il ya un
certain nombre d'effets secondaires
minimes très minime et on est en train
de surveiller les choses alors la
question posée chez les ados qui est une
très bonne question
on est là en train de parler des douze
saisons des 12-18 ans 1 selon la
définition et si on se situe elle se
situe dans les questions bénéfice/risque
où ces ados sont des éléments de
transmission mais où le risque que le
provoqué par le comique est pratiquement
nul
et c'est on est dans dance dans cet
aspect bénéfice risque alors ce qui nous
a fait peut-être un peu évolué en france
par ap mais il ya d'autres pays qui nous
ont suivis et en europe il ya des pays
qui sont plus plus limité dans cette
dans cette indication
c'est d'entendre les pédiatres je vous
rappelle que la france est quand même le
pays européen qui a le plus conserver
les enfants à l'école
il ya des choses clients qui comme
marche on a le plus conserver les
enfants à l'école que l'ouverture des
écoles en septembre reste une priorité
majeure
et on sait aussi qu'il va y avoir une
contamination très importante dans cette
population mode septembre c'est clair
les données de la situation le montrer
clairement donc limité je dirais pour
septembre octobre avec une avec une une
stratégie vaccinale est logique et ce
qui nous a fait peut-être basculé dans
ce dans cette difficulté de mesurer le
bénéfice risque c'est de sortir du coc
vide entre guillemets et c'est le les
pédiatres qui disent attention santé
mentale et pédiatrie le retentissement
des enfants qui doit en particulier là
aussi dans les milieux défavorisés
mais le retentissement psychique de ne
pas aller à l'école de voir les voir les
écoles s'interrompent et c est un
élément très fort les ai sûrement
entendu à une autre période d'écouter
les pédopsychiatres qui sont qui pensent
que c'est qu'on a affaire à quelque
chose sur le long terme et les le moyen
terme
le deuxième élément c'est que pour la
population jeune et en particulier
plutôt les 16 18 ans il ya quelque chose
dont on ne parle jamais donc du coup
j'en profite celle que vit de long le
club de lens est pas nul s'essaieront
d'où je reviens âge un autre jour peut
être à la rentrée si vous m'invitez sur
le corridor c'est c'est un point très
importante c'est à dire que ça va nous
rester ensuite avec des gens qui est des
gens jeunes qui seront passés pas avec
une forme sévère aux graves mais qui
vont faire un coup violent et donc les
deux éléments pour finalement vaccinées
c'est leur éviter un kobe de long dans
une population très jeune et
deuxièmement la santé psychique
après il n'ya rien d'imposé et moi j'ai
fait très attention criaient aussi le
consentement qui puisse être demandé aux
enfants je viens le voir avec ma petite
fille alors que je ne porte pas le même
nom qui a été prise par le centre de
vaccination qui l'a qui a demandé à sa
mère de sortir et qui a interrogé ma
petite fille en disant c'est bien toi
qui as donné ton d'accord fait pas sous
pression de ses parents que je trouve ça
très bien très très bien compte que les
équipes médicales s'engage dans ce type
là et puis on est passé
je crois qu'on va y aller doucement on
est passé on a démarré à 12% de vacciner
je crois qu'on est autour de 19 au 21 %
aux pays-bas ils sont 55% en angleterre
un peu comme nous et en allemagne il
démarre et aux etats unis ils sont très
très largement partie voilà je crois que
j'ai répondu à peu près à vos questions
excusez moi mais permettez que je vous
dise que vous n'avez pas répondu sur les
choix vaccination nos territoires
je vois merci pardon des choix le choix
des vaccins parce qu'on a focalisé le
choix c'était le choix du vaccin je sais
voilà on est je vous explique et on va
essayer de vous expliquer l'importance
qu'avait par exemple sur les deux
vaccins et mais reina le fait qu'on
était à trois semaines et une semaine de
cons on était dans un dans un schéma
global de 1 mois ce qui permettait non
pas de répondre à la vague de fin août
mais de répondre à ce qui se passerait
après fin août donc à mes yeux c'est du
point de vue opérationnel
après si des gens ne veulent absolument
pas être vaccinés par un vaccin de type
a et rennes il faut savoir les écouter
sa chevauchée j'ai rien à dire contre ça
après ce tracé des cas on rentre quand
même là dans un autre problème de
bénéfices ris je n'y reviens pas et il
ya en effet le janssen et il va y avoir
d'autres vaccins qui vont arriver
il ya un certain nombre de gentils parmi
les i
en dix mois je me ferai vacciner quand
j'aurai avec cinq français et qui ne
sera pas de type arm
bon je pense que c'est une sorte de
fuite en avant
mais si c'est finalement ça qu'ils ont
en tête bien on va pas vacciner les 95%
de la population d'ici des d'ici le mois
de septembre donc bah ils attendront qui
on va leur demander de prendre des
précautions en attendant épuiseront le
vaccin de sanofi quand il va sortir
donc moi je je suis pour pousser aller
vers le pass sanitaire qui une fois de
plus c'était votre question initiale
aura peut-être terminée là dessus c'est
c'est dans cet enjeu de comment à la
fois les libertés individuelles
auxquelles je tiens beaucoup comme vous
tous doivent s'effacer un certain moment
devant une liberté collective est la
seule façon de garder une liberté
collective et de ne pas retourner à des
mesures de restriction petit fort et de
type couvre-feu fort ou de type
confinement et bien c'est d'aller vers
cette vaccination il passe sanitaire
[Musique]